hey guys I am just with Donnell y'all
watching games but he's top five the
show where I give you my five favorite
stories of the week you tell me yours
and we'll have a chat over it and it'll
be a thing orientation irva and let's go
[Music]
this week marcus off told the world when
they'll be having their e3 briefing and
alluded to what they'll be announcing
June 9th at 9:30 a.m. PDT will be the
date and time to keep in mind if you
want to see it live phil spencer has
said he wants the showing to be more fan
focused this year and they're calling
the event xbox game on marks softer
currently promising you'll hear more
about previously announced games as well
as unannounced games coming in 2014 and
beyond so everything i guess they'll be
talking about everything the
International Data Corporation made a
bunch of predictions this week including
the fact that they reckon the ps4 will
outsell the Xbox one by selling 51
million units by 2016 while their report
initially claimed the ps4 would come out
on top it also suggested that the Xbox
one could recover and reclaim the top
but by unbundling the Kinect next year
the IDC thinks the given that this would
ultimately bring down the price
consumers would be much more interested
in the cheaper console sans Kinect
resulting in a spike in sales for
Microsoft next up dice have confirmed
that you will be getting a glimpse of
Star Wars Battlefront at e3 next month
even though EA says the game has loads
of work to go on till it'll be complete
it will be among the games that the
publisher will be presenting no word yet
on if the game will be playable or not
but unless we hear anymore but EA's
other Star Wars projects the earth and
world one developed by Visceral Games
and xnor IDO creatively Amy Hennig
battlefront will be the best place to
get your Star Wars fixed Sony have
praised indie games this week by calling
them the heartbeat of gaming Sony VP of
developer and publisher relations
boys told CVG that promoting creativity
and new ideas is the most important
thing in the industry to hinge in
reference to the relationship between
PlayStation and indie gaming he said we
care very deeply about it we limit and
breathe it and bleed it when were with
these people they're our friends these
the people we respect he then very
rightly called it a love fest and said
that the indie presence on ps4 and Vita
is much better than that on ps3 and
PlayStation Portable and in my favorite
story of the week the u.s. is terrorized
Denmark well in Minecraft the Danish
geodata agency tried to recreate the
country of Denmark in Minecraft and a
one-to-one scale which is awesome and
amounted to one of the biggest minecraft
creations ever and then players started
blowing it up although the use of
dynamite was disabled the minecart with
dynamite in it was not so from the
rubble of Denmark rose American flags
and tanks to their credit Denmark being
Denmark didn't really mind and said
we're very happy to see so many players
around the world creating fancy nice
things and having fun let me know where
your favorite story of the week was
either by leaving a comment in that
commenting section down below or you can
let me know on my Twitter where I'm at
Jeff McDonald this week on site Danny
runs you over the history of Nazis in
video games I talk steam machines and
what's working money on the gist and
reality check covers off on real life
superhuman strength that is it for me
this week but I hope you enjoyed our
jiya sneeze offerings and be sure to
have yourself a lovely weekend
[Music]